hängt das war ist mein kompromiss ok ihn
getötet waffe weg waffe weg services und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und ich bin heute zurück mit einer neuen
challenge für euch wir werden heute die
einweg schwerter zellen spielen wie die
funktioniert das ist so die schwerter
sind der zentrale punkt in dieser
challenge und zwar folgendermaßen jedes
mal wenn ich im deathmatch also im
entscheid ein schwert benutzer und mit
diesem schwert einen gegner töten muss
ich dieses schwert sofort wegwerfen und
entsorgen und das nicht mehr weiter
benutzen auch nicht um den anderen
irgendein anderer gegen auch nur ein
hinzugeben
sie müssen ins land entsorgt werden so
das ist jetzt das ist die challenge und
das ist relativ schwierig weil ich so
durchschnittlich vielleicht so fünf
sechs oder sieben kills im deathmatch
mache das heißt ich bräuchte eigentlich
um optimal kämpfen zu können
fünf sechs oder sieben schwerter in der
variante die jetzt das beste schwärmt
für mich ist das heißt wenn ich jetzt
wenn man besser spätesten stein schwert
ist bräuchte ich um normal spielen zu
können
5 stein schwerter weil ich nach nach
durchschnittlich 5 kills mit jedes mal
wieder mal einen stein statt wegwerfen
dann neues stadt brauche so das wird
natürlich so nicht funktionieren weil
man nicht fünf streitwerte findet auch
nicht wenn man alle kisten blutet und
auch die vom gegenüber noch mit war man
noch mit fleischiges rüber geht das wird
nicht klappen das heißt dass death match
wird relativ schwierig und knackig ich
versuche jetzt einfach mit freu mich so
darauf vorzubereiten dass ich einfach
möglichst viele schwerter sammeln
schwerter äxte whatever egal welche
waffen auch die holz sachs von anfragen
die werfe ich nicht weg heute in dieser
runde
denn ich habe keinen bock dann am ende
dazu stehen und einfach keine waffe mehr
im deathmatch zu haben weil man wirklich
keine waffe mehr hat dann hat man
gelitten wenn man nur die holz hat kann
man immer noch irgend ein bisschen
abstauben darum bayern oder sonst was
aber wenn man keine waffen hat dann wird
es auch mit dem abstauben ziemlich
schwierig so wir gucken mal kurz in
unser equipment in goldwörth 2 stein
äxte eine holzes geht würde ich sagen
dafür dass wir noch nicht so weit
fortgeschritten in der runde sind die
rund läuft
nein 88 minuten
denke ich mir mein ziel da hinten wir
auch die justin ja okay sie übersehen
gut gold rüstung alles klar
ich habe mir dann noch mal überhaupt hat
eben schon mal eine test aufnahme
gemacht oder einem testspiel dieser
challenge und da war es dann so dass man
relativ schnell doch wieder an schwerter
kam weil die leute die gedruckt haben
ich glaub das lag aber daran dass
einfach alle leute die ich da mit meinem
schwert angegriffen habe nur auch ein
leben hatten
und normalerweise haben die ja drei ein
bisschen der clou an der sache nur wenn
man die leute tötet heißt es ja nicht
dass sie auch gleich ihre kiste droppen
und den ganzen see mend a broken weil
die drei leben haben wenn man das letzte
leben verliert hat man erst ein event
vorgeben
schön schön schön schön schön aber
problematisch leute ich wir finden jetzt
gar keine waffen die letzten beiden
kisten hatten beide keine einzige waffe
die wieder nicht alter all ship nach wie
vor vier schwerter und ich verliere kurz
runter weil ich noch besoffen bin voll
von geschichten möchte mein letzter
nacht mal wieder ziemlich lange in
minecraft universe da meinen mainz
kinder wieder richtig hart gesagt von
letzter nacht deswegen hat jetzt gerade
rückwärts oder gefallen und hier auf die
leiter sehr schön und das mitnehmen ok
kurz gedacht dass ich da auch runter
fallen würde so kurz vom blog das ist
das bitterste was über diesen moment
kennt wenn ihr einfach so kurz davor
seitenblick module zu finishen und dann
einfach form gelben block bei dem
leichtesten sprung aller zeiten einfach
verkackt und ihr wollte ich so selbst
mit vollem anlauf ins gesicht schlagen
okay okay wie geht das
das ist glaube ich auch ein bisschen
tricky hier ist alles neue modul ich
habe dieses modul auch noch nie gespielt
was wir jetzt gerade hier sehen
so kann man es machen und dann wohl da
hinten raus ja und jetzt oh das ist
nicht so leicht hier kurz mal
konzentrieren
ja ja jetzt hier um die ecke
nein da war irgendetwas da haben wir im
block oben draufgesetzt alter wie gemein
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen hat mich
darauf geachtet ist das gemeine alter
okay da muss ich ein bisschen näher ran
das macht es auch nicht gerade leicht
hier dieser einstieg in diese höhle
schon ziemlich strikt die wahlen
normalerweise geht dieser sprung so dass
man hat einfach sprinter bisschen später
ab sprechen dann kann man auch wenn man
keinen blog über sich platz hat noch
fliegen aber hier ist es nicht so easy
weil es das hier auf einmal öffnet wenn
man zu spät abspringt hat man noch mal
wieder die normale sprung entfernung ok
und fliegt dann einfach viel zu weit um
auf diesem blog dazu landen
konzentrieren wollen nicht ewig in
diesem modul hängenbleiben es passiert
leider sehr oft wenn man sich einmal
irgendwie ein schießt oder einmal an
einem ort hängen bleibt dann dann
verkackt man ja auch an so unnötige
stellen wie die den hier zum beispiel
das sollte eigentlich nicht sein aber es
ist halt einfach es sei für sie das
leben
ok hey hey recruiting nation los mit
euch goal.com jetzt
kommen jetzt komm jetzt komplett kommerz
hier runter und nice nice mein alter
2000 jahre später richtig ab ihr könnt
ihr mal reinschauen ob er das auch kennt
rösler beim modul acht ja mini tour ohne
witz dieses modul acht hier dieses leyen
begrüßte so eklig falls jetzt schon mal
gespielt habt schreiben reinalter wort
hat aber jetzt geht s los ok vor sich so
leute jetzt müssen wir jedes mal wenn
wir einen gegner töten die waffe mit der
wir den gegner getötet haben
wegschmeißen
es geht los ich fange erst damit dieses
die axt an das ist nie meine beste waffe
damit kann man keine pfeile blocken habe
ich noch in die rüstung geht meine
rüstung ist in ordnung ist nicht
blamabel und das habe hier ja ok laut
eppenstein stadt fängt erst war erst
meine leiste kompromiss ok ihn getötet
waffe weg weg weg openoffice
weggeschmissen hab's gesehen so wie
kommen sie bekommen jetzt meine waffe
wieder auf den waffen start auf die 1
ich hänge ok herum wenig hinterher von
brot essen so was nehmen wir als
nächstes okay noch mal die stacks
erstmal die access weg ball ein
ich muss halt auch echt haushalten mit
den waffen da vorne weil uns die kiste
nicht mal guten sollen ja combox komme
ich jetzt rein die daumen gedanke was
dir doch gerade eben gegeneinander
gekämpft wie sie nicht gestorben
okay aber das gute ist ich habe jetzt
nicht getötet das heißt ich muss meine
waffe noch nicht wegschmeißen
aber erstmal nicht die gleiche lage
verändert habe das war gab es in 16 sie
hat einfach wir uns gleich für die hits
verteilten sehr direkter vorgekämpft
normalerweise ist die region nicht so
schnell dass man wenn man direkt danach
kämpft schon wieder voll gerecht ist
komisch egal weiter wir sollten auch auf
jeden fall schauen
ich spiele einfach drauf case also ich
werde jetzt vielleicht nicht den
absoluten hatte in eisenachs wir leben
hat der kfc so gut so gut da hat ein
leben hat er vielleicht eine eisenachs
dann hole ich mir den ich mir die
eisenachs von dem das vergleich
sonntags mal lieber die stimmlage bei
der ami go trabi go oder steinachs kurz
gucken kriegst du hinten
es war eine sachs und wie viele pfeile
alter schwede habe ich auch keinen bogen
bitte jetzt gibt er an ein gegner sie
sollen aufhören nicht anzufassen
aber ich muss ich muss erstmal meine
steinachs wegschmeißen so da kann ich
jetzt die eisenachs nehmen so als müsse
gucken kenne auch keinen bogen kräften
was ist mit dir hier
lasst das fechten
ich glaube dir würden zu ächten
ich hoffe ich habe jetzt mein liegt mein
mikro nicht ausgezogen und ich hoffen
kabel da unten
goch so jetzt okay ich gehe erst mit dem
mit der eisenachs in den wald rein
ok förster des meeres erkennt auch ja
was ist das für eine combo alter was das
für eine combo naja ok nice ich habe sie
getötet alter motto rationiert auf
einmal so eine eklige kommen wo
ausgepackt ich kann überhaupt nicht ran
aber da habe ich noch bekommen junge so
aber jetzt muss ich die waffe
wegschmeißen ich muss die nächste nehmen
und jetzt habe ich nur noch einen
goldwert die drei leben auch noch das
heißt ich muss meinen letzten freitag
mit dem holzschwert kämpfen
ok ja bitte gott ist mein ich habe gott
nein nein ok holt mich um mich als
stärkerer schwer tun sich da einfach ein
schlagabtausch gibt jeder hat den
anderen einmal eigene was ist einmal
gleichmäßig dann ist einfach das stärker
schwert am ende in der oberhand
ok jetzt probieren wir es
was kann ich machen ich kann doch
überall tnt einsetzen will ich auf jeden
fall auch jetzt hat sich irgendwie laut
grund hier kurz mal gucken vielleicht
bisschen weg bisschen weg von hier kommt
es zu mehr wir wollen das schon
verhalten klar läuft so lange bis ich
sie für mich gerät lassen sich lieb von
wehr oder ich sage aber ich sag der ist
von der also von mädchen
so kammer und common man ein hat gefehlt
nein ok keine chance keine chance die
waffe versteckt obwohl ich vorsteht
hatte jemand hatte sie so gute rüstung
leder boots die hat im moment mal 3 506
leistungspunkt ich hatte nicht viel
weniger komisch auf jeden fall das war
die heutige challenge richtig richtig
tricky dass man seine waffen immer
wegschmeißen könnte selbst ausprobieren
internet um meine kommentare schreiben
wie das bei euch so war und dieses neue
modul was ihr davon haltet ich finde es
richtig eklig aber das war jetzt auch in
der auf der messe an der situation wie
ihrem auto